the story at the heart of gucci is
extraordinary there are a lot of rumors
around
it has got passions it's got family it's
got feuding it's got loves and loathings
and tragedy even murder
it's better to cry in rolls-royce than
to be happy in basically
that story is really the appeal and the
excitement and yes the sex factor
of a brand like gucci
sometimes things happen in life to
change your life this was really success
beyond my wildest imagination
i didn't believe possible tom did not
believe it was possible
the success was unbelievable
it's difficult to understate just how
successful the gucci brand has been in
history but also really is right now
we're looking at a brand value of
something like 15 billion dollars and
that's underpinned by an extraordinary
social media following so you both got
this business value and also you've got
this dynamism in the digital world that
combination
has really been the key to gucci's
success
there's been an unfairness to give a lot
of credit to people who really didn't
deserve all that credit and instead
people who had deserved credit were
totally forgotten nobody has focused on
the real story everybody has focused on
the fairy tale
that's very good news for the viewers
and maybe also for the media but it's
not a reality
there is an epic saying in italy when it
comes to you know family generations
that the first generation
creates
the second generation expands and the
third generation destroys
and that's almost what happened in in
the gucci story
you've got the founder who was guccio
gucci who had the vision for making
quality leather goods and selling them
you know initially to american tourists
and other other european travelers
and then you have his two sons
rodolfo and aldo who ended up having
each 50 of the company
and
especially aldo was was really the the
marketer and the expander and he had a
vision to take gucci outside of italy
and then you have the third generation
which is also where a lot of the
conflict started because you had
aldo's three sons roberto giorgio and
paulo and they had 50 together with
their father and then you have maurizio
on the other side a single child who
inherited 50 percent from his father
rodolfo
[Music]
the gucci story was really punctuated by
the family conflicts and they were
extremely litigious so all of these
fights spilled out you know into open
court and became extremely public
one of the characters that really had
the longest arc and almost the most
knowledge about the story was domenico
de sole
who started as a lawyer to rodolfo in
the early 80s
so hi domenico hi how are you so what
was it like working for rodolfo and then
dealing with aldo it was it was very
complicated because uh that point what
was happening there was a big conflict
in the family because aldo's children
probably felt that their dad had done
such a phenomenal job which is true aldo
was a pretty formidable person but they
felt that they deserve more than the one
fourth or fifty percent so we had a lot
of battle that went on and on for a long
time but then the situation was
basically confirmed and there was no
change in the the shareholder ownership
and maurizio kept the 50 percent and
that was the situation but that created
a lot of animosity there were a lot of
battle
he dreams every five minutes he doesn't
think he dreams and in his own life it's
still run
as a child today we do 138 million
dollars business with 18 million dollar
profit
this is the answer to a dream i accept
so a major turning point in this family
story was 1983 rodolfo is very ill and
he dies
and he leaves his 50 stake in the
company to his only son mauricio
maurizio is starting to get his ideas
even back then about how he wants to
clean up the gucci brand and take it up
market but he can't get his uncle and
his cousins on board they're very happy
with all of the lucrative licensing
deals that that are very profitable for
them
so as maurizio is becoming more and more
convinced of his vision for gucci and
that he's the one who needs to take it
forward on the home front he's also
falling out with his wife patricia who
had been pushing him to be the kind of
mr gucci and one of the leading luxury
ceos in milan but he's starting to feel
a little bit pressed and in 1985 he
decides to leave her
we have this
transformation
mr jackie became dr hyde
the same time you had paulo ratting on
his father aldo to the u.s tax
authorities because he suspected his
father of siphoning off profits and
putting them into offshore accounts so
there was a case then started by the irs
an investigation that ended up sending
aldo to jail
i never forget i remember with a board
meeting of gucci america and mauricio
asked me and said you have to explain
what this means and yes i'm trying to
explain to the mercenary family this is
the united states it's very serious and
tax fraud is very serious it's not italy
one member of the board said to me you
are pessimistic i said maybe what do you
want me to say
unfortunately i did go to jail at that
point
again it's a big change in my life
because i went from being the lawyer for
the for the company and the family he
asked me to run gucci america
and it
with a specific goal of settling with
the irs
the reputation was still a very good
reputation most importantly worldwide
name recognition because other really
geniuses they open stores in places like
japan in in hong kong in asia you know
they're really amazing early on they
were in all these markets but there was
a problem i think the product was really
getting to be less attractive they also
expanded distribution dramatically so
there were a lot of events
that occurred that really
the the brand was deteriorating
there are many lessons from luxury brand
history about the balance between brand
value and revenue growth
because frankly it can be easy to get
over excited about the possibility of
revenue growth
increased distribution and of course
gucci have had their own issues and
challenges on losing control of the
brand experience in and out of their
history there have been times when they
have over expanded they lost control of
product quality in their drive for
international success
what is it that makes the brand valuable
it will often be exclusivity it'll be
the control of the customer experience
that people can feel confident about
what they're going to get in product
terms what they're going to get in
service terms and also the authenticity
that they're going to get as part of
what they're buying and so therefore you
need to make sure you are feeding that
brand value or what it is that makes the
brand valuable in the first place
so manito had a problem because he he
had a clear vision for gucci
but he didn't have the money to buy out
his relatives
the answer to his problem was an
investment banker who worked for morgan
stanley at the time named andrea morante
[Music]
i can remember very vividly as if it
were yesterday that when i
explained
to the other partners in the room the
morgan stanley room
that i had met with mauricio gucci
and that he wanted to do some form of
shareholding restructuring
i'll never forget that for the first
time when i was describing a transaction
everybody was interested and that's if
you will the first time that i
understood the power of a brand
so he launches this plan the stealth
campaign with morgan stanley to buy up
the shares of aldo and his cousins and
bring in an investment bank invest corps
as his financial partner because he
didn't have enough money to just buy it
all himself
as far as the complexity of purchasing
the cousins and the also the uncle well
that complexity
had one solution which
you could call today inside information
because i spent a lot of time with
maurizio he gave me all the inside
information of what everybody within the
family really what the agenda was and in
particular he also explained to me how
paolo gucci
had been ill-treated by his father and
given
a significant reduced number of shares
vis-a-vis his brothers because
paolo had literally
took his father to jail
so what i did is i proposed to him
to be paid
a very similar amount of money as if he
had not been
penalized by his father
i'll pay you the same price
that your brothers are going to be
receiving
he accepted so i actually went there
with
a suitcase of cash and purchased this
initial three percent from paolo gucci
which actually changed the life of gucci
one person who worked for the company
said paulo has been a traitor to
everyone
yes maybe yes you know
against bandits i mean if you leave them
and you're a traitor right
once they saw that the game was over and
there was somebody else coming to
actually run the business then gradually
one by one they all sold their shares
so
what initially was almost a mission
impossible turned into a reality 50
of all the available shares were
ultimately purchased by invescorp and at
that stage inverscorp and maurizio had
the company
so mauricio emerges as the ceo he had
control because even though he was in a
50 50
agreement with invescore they gave him
you know management control his vision
was to take gucci backup market and that
meant you know quality products
beautiful workmanship and he had a very
classic idea of what he wanted gucci to
be he used to say
he wanted to be round and brown and soft
to a woman's hand he opened this
fabulous headquarters in milan no
expense spared priceless antiques
workmanship so the debt started racking
up really really fast and at the same
time he had cut out the most lucrative
parts of the business so the gucci
accessories collection which was the
cash cow for the company
things were done in a somewhat
irrational way i think that incurred
massive costs
any language the company could not
afford at the time for instance he
decided to clean an old new product okay
wow that's a great idea but you know
what's the cost of it so overnight he
said no more gg so i said mauricio gg is
like 70 percent of the sales but he
wanted to do it all costs so the company
really went to you know tailspin and
started really losing money and was very
very difficult became very painful
so the situation became dire with
gucci's finances they were not able to
pay salaries
they were not able to pay suppliers they
were
on the verge of having to take the
company's books into court to say they
couldn't settle the accounts and at that
point that means the company's declared
bankruptcy so gucci is really teetering
on the brink at this stage
he had to write these things i think
that the problem he couldn't make it
happen there's some people have great
vision but he had the greatest vision
the great strategy but if you execute he
was incapable really beyond incapable of
executing that's really what's the
bottom line
so invest corp after giving you know
maurizio free reign to put his vision
into place
they're becoming very very worried about
the situation and they are millions of
dollars in the hole
and they're deciding they don't want to
put any more money in because they think
it's just going down the drain
i told him that it was in his best
interest
in order to keep and preserve the good
relationship he had had with invescorp
to go to in the scope and say let's
choose a common
new
chief executive officer somebody who's
really going to operate the business and
so when i told him that
unfortunately the reaction was extremely
negative because for him
i was
telling him which is the truth that he
was not capable
to run the company
and i felt the responsibility of telling
him that
in his own interest but sometimes you
know your own interest is perceived in a
different way
he is begging them for time
his assessment is that the turnaround
needs a little more time for the
customers to really get the feeling for
how gucci has changed and at one point
he's begging them if you just give me
six months he says the japanese market
is going to realize that there's a new
gucci and the wind will be back in our
sails well he never got that chance
inviscor
created a war room
they went after him with everything they
could and finally they were successful
in kicking him out and they bought his
50
in the company for 150 million dollars
and then took it over entirely
the irony of this story was that
actually maurizio was right six months
after he was forced out by invescore uh
the japanese woke up to the new gucci
and started buying you know gucci bags
and and the company started making money
you know hand over fist in a very quick
time
in march of 1995 one morning broad
daylight maritzu is walking into the
front door of his new offices a gunman
comes into the doorway behind him and
shoots him dead in cold blood
[Music]
the murder of maurizio gucci it was a
shocking event for the city and
in addition to being shocking it was
very sinister because there was no clear
culprit the prosecutor who was
investigating the case was looking into
his business deals he was looking into
the family conflicts he interviewed the
cousins he interviewed patricia but he
didn't really see a clear family
connection
and the case was just cold after two
years
until because of a tipster one day one
morning at 5 30 in the morning the
police raid patriz's apartment on corso
venezia and arrest her for maritzia's
murder
she had an obsession
she wanted her husband dead
and she spoke about it to everyone
[Music]
often people are remembered for the
wrong reasons and the glamour and maybe
the interest
has more to do
with the homicide a wife appoints a
killer you know a hit man
and perhaps there is a risk that
maurizio will indeed be remembered as
somebody who was killed by his wife for
no reason at all or for very good
reasons depending on where on where you
sit
but i think that
maurizio's real legacy is the taguchi
brand has really been created by three
generations
as often is the case in some family
businesses
after the third generation
the family is not able to keep control
of the company
in this case mauricio not only lost
control of the company but he also lost
his life
in the early stages of many luxury
brands the founder
you know the visionary the original
creative director they came almost to
the end of their tenure and they needed
somebody else to take the brand on in a
different direction or a fresh direction
i think you could also say with the
gucci brand say 100 years old over time
a brand like that needs to have fresh
input and fresh eyes
[Music]
so even though mauricio wasn't
ultimately successful in putting his
vision in place he had actually done a
lot of the work to set gucci up for its
next phase
he hired an american retail executive
dawn mello who was the president of
bergdorf goodman at the time and one of
her main contributions was to hire tom
ford
after mauricio left they started giving
me more and more responsibility and i
became the chief operating officer of
the company very quickly and at that
point
i really the fact i was running a
company they basically asked me who i
thought that to be the creative director
and i felt very strongly to be tom i
remember
very busy i drove up to milan and tom
was very very young we had a meeting and
i said tom
i think we can really fix this company
so i said look i'm not interested in
interfering i'm a businessman i don't
pretend to be a creative person by any
means so you're in charge you know you
do it and and let's see where we go here
he accepted and that's really the
beginning of the story
he bought back the logo and made it chic
he makes clothes that rocked the world
and he puts sex back where it belongs
here's tom ford for gucci thank you i
i'd like to thanks bob
thank you
thank you
it's difficult to understate the impact
of tom ford on gucci no it's not just
about fashion it's also about real life
with his extraordinary style his
innovation and actually his sense of
control
this is one of the really really key
success criteria
there has to be a vision
and it has to be
a very direct vision
tom ford had a very very clear and
strong idea about what gucci could be in
terms of global ambition he made sure
that his vision was totally controlled
right across the customer experience
from the advertising every point of
communication product detail and so on
ford's design power hit the fashion
world like a tidal wave the winner is
and the winner is tom hard
thank you
[Music]
so the tom dumb era of gucci really was
extraordinarily exciting and it was
clear from the very first menswear show
actually that tom designed in florence
that something had changed at gucci and
there was a new gucci in the air
and sales took off immediately
and even though they were showing kind
of more sexy styles on the runway they
were still selling primarily black and
brown handbags but they really had lit a
fire under this brand and the sales are
doubling
so the sales went through the roof in
1995
our sale doubled the success was just
unbelievable suddenly really things
looked up and that at that point
investor wanted to go public as fast as
possible
so the gucci ipo was very anticipated
but what they realized was that there
was no fashion sector in the financial
market so they actually had to train
analysts in how the luxury market worked
and so domenico is being given
presentation workshops and skills they
are bringing analysts into the room and
talking about how the industry works
they really pioneered the luxury sector
in the financial market and other brands
you know subsequently followed but it
was really the gucci ipo that set the
stage the old gucci name sure is
attracting a lot of customers these days
on main street and wall street the ipo
of gucci was
even more successful than their wildest
dreams they debuted at 22 dollars and
shot immediately up to 26 dollars
the offering was 14 times oversubscribed
and ended up making more than 2 billion
for inviscor sales were up 113
so we were delighted there was a fifth
quarter in a row with which we double
our sale
it proved to be
a success story
certainly from a financial perspective
for inverse corp
but also a huge success story within the
industry
once it was clear
that the luxury markets was there to be
developed and was there to be taken
advantage of
all the players
who were already in that market
had the competitive advantage
of having seen it from within
the risk was that somebody could take it
over given this massive success and it
doesn't matter successfully you are with
a public company also always moment in
which the stock may go down in 1997
gucci was a high performance machine but
a financial crisis hit asia putting
gucci and the rest of the luxury goods
market in
peril japan was the dominant force in
the luxury market
at the time so when there was this
crisis in asia the stock went down and i
think at that point was lbmh started
purchasing shares of the company that's
really was my concern about the
possibility of to be open to a takeover
so the real sort of rival on the market
for gucci was lvmh and bernardo no who
was kind of known as a as a corporate
raider in the european luxury scene he
had taken over louis vuitton what nsc
and had other fashion brands sia dior
we try to
build a large business with our partners
with one criteria the best quality
and the most
elitist products in every line
that we are selling throughout the world
i got a call from ev carcel who's the
ceo of louis vuitton and he called me
told me that lbmh has purchased five
percent of the company and at that time
if you went about a five percent
threshold under the rule in your stock
exchange you had to go public with it so
that was really the beginning of the
battle with lvmh and did he say
something about how it was a friendly
acquisition yeah he said it was very
very friendly and he said well you know
i know
i know it's a hell of a reputation so
i'm not sure how friendly this is gonna
be
now we're gonna mix a little money with
a lot of style from january through june
two retail titans battle for control of
fashion's biggest prize the house of
gucci
so once arno had thrown down the
gauntlet for gucci domenico de sole
realized that he was in for a big fight
and he pulled in
bankers and advisors and decided to
stage a resistance and his main concern
was that he didn't want arno to be able
to take over control of the company
without offering a full and fair offer
to all shareholders
they are our number one competitor we
compete against them for
customers we compete for talent people
this is a case of creeping control they
would like to control the company
without paying the full price
the
contest between these two companies was
getting more and more acrimonious
and with the help of his advisors desola
put protection mechanism into place
through the issuing of employee shares
and that kept on diluting our no stake
is he's building up his his stake in the
company but at a certain point de soy
realizes that they aren't going to be
able to fend off or no forever so kind
of in the ninth hour francois pino who
runs ppr which was a french retail group
comes in and offers to buy a stake in
gucci and becomes the white knight to
help them fight off i don't know
francois was the most decisive man in
the history of the universe i talked to
him for half an hour i told my story and
i explained
why we want to defend
against her no desolate drove a hard
bargain securing 3 billion for gucci's
immediate growth it was the very deal
bernard arno rejected
so francois pino does not only want to
be the white knight but he has an even
bigger idea and so he turns yves
three billion dollars over to tom and
dom and he says i want you kind of the
dream team of fashion to buy up other
brands and turn gucci into a multi-brand
group that can rival our no and lvmh
that was pretty brutal because we were
under pressure to do it okay so it was
just a lot of work you know there were a
lot of potential targets and every time
we tried to buy something obviously lvmh
would show up it was not an easy thing
to lose everything to be done in great
secrecy it was a huge amount of pressure
because
it was on one end running the company
and on the other hand acquiring all
these companies and we acquired a lot of
companies very fast
to
not only turn around gucci or keep the
gucci turnaround going but to also then
identify other talent other brands
make them successful i mean it became a
huge endeavor
they were both working 24 7.
tom was designing both gucci and yves
saint laurent
and at the same time they were trying to
identify and then
nurture these other designers i was
looking for major investment and then
gucci got in touch and molested his
history
they bought alexander mcqueen they
bought stella mccartney they bought
valenciaga each brand was slightly
different you know some were young
designers that needed sort of help to
grow and to mature others were faded
names that needed to be turned around so
they had a lot of children
that they were trying to raise
in this endeavor
there was the agreement that we would
run the company independently for five
years create these multi-brand companies
large group of companies and then it
would buy hundred percent of the share
the price that being set forth at the
time
of the battle with lvmh
so five years after the initial white
knight pinot buys the full 100 of gucci
and you know tom and dom are in a
situation where they are essentially
running this publicly traded company as
though it were their own until a time
comes where pinot is taking control
and it's time to renegotiate the
contracts for tom and domenico
and they realize that they they aren't
going to have the freedom to run gucci
the way they had been and
tom and dom announced that they're
resigning from gucci which is kind of a
shock to the industry at that time
so at the end tom was clear was not
going to stay and i worked with him so
closely you know just like my my my
younger brother so at the end we felt
and i felt that we'd done our part and
it was time to move on with life
the partnership between tom and domenico
really became foundational not only for
the gucci business but for
other luxury houses that were starting
to replicate this synergy between the
creative and and the management it
became seen as kind of the the essential
component that you needed in that period
to run a successful luxury brand
gucci is my my legacy so i love the
company and
i'm super happy about gucci sugar some
people
ask me this question a lot no i always
wanted gucci to do well you know i think
would have been catastrophic iguchi
didn't do well after tom and i left
the genius in many ways of gucci is how
it's been able to reinvent
itself and also frankly reinvent the sex
of its times
if we think about
how gucci was rescued in the 1990s
sex sells and that contemporary view on
sex was a fundamentally important part
of that
now we've seen gucci really go ahead
again the last few years have been
phenomenally successful now why is that
well actually they've expressed sex in a
rather different way a gender blending
sex a non-binary type of sex that has
really really resonated
with millennials and consumers under the
age of 35 and that has been both very
unusual it's been very challenging for
luxury brands but of course gucci have
made it a truly runaway and runway
success
you